the january 6th committee opened public
hearing number two with a focus on
election night 2020 inside the white
house where donald trump and his
advisors watched the election returns
with increasing worry the fox news
decision desk is calling arizona for joe
biden
that is a big
get for the biden campaign did that
shift the atmosphere the attitude
in the white house
completely
it was becoming clear that the race
would not be called
on election night
witnesses say trump was livid and
ignored their advice to wait before
making a public statement they said he
instead turned to his private attorney
rudy giuliani who was described as drunk
the mayor was definitely intoxicated
mayor giuliani was saying we want it
they're stealing it from us where'd all
the votes come from
we need to go say that we won
and
essentially that anyone who didn't agree
with that position was being weak
a defiant trump then declared his false
victory
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
this was the fox news political editor
later fired from his job after calling
arizona for biden after the election as
of november
7th
in your judgment what were the chances
of president trump winning the election
after that point yes none
in the weeks that followed trump would
continue to spread the lies of
widespread voter fraud despite being
told by attorney general william barr
that the claim was bogus i was
somewhat demoralized because i thought
boy if he really believes this stuff he
has you know
lost contact with with
he's become detached from reality
over and over witnesses testified that
trump refused to accept his election
defeat despite the growing evidence
otherwise not only was there not
evidence of 8 000 dead voters
voting in pennsylvania there wasn't
evidence of eight
the former president's media campaign
spread the election falsehoods
invigorating his base supporters donated
250 million dollars to trump's so-called
election defense fund
investigators testified the fund didn't
exist and that some of the money went to
trump's hotel collection and the event
company that organized the january 6
rally not only was there the big lie
there was the big ripoff
the committee plans another half dozen
public hearings to connect the election
lies with the violence of january 6.
they say evidence will show that trump
tried to corrupt the justice department
and when that failed assembled the mob
that would try to keep him in power by
force heidi jo castro al jazeera
washington